alain bashung bonsoir alors on a reçu
ici à quelques semaines ton complice
tombe parolier halte et parolier boris
bergman qui nous a appris une bien
triste nouvelle puisqu'il nous a dit que
maintenant après novice c'était fini
quoi je me suis rendu compte dans le
truc c'est que
plus on se fréquentait comme ça plus on
parlait et moi on écrivait des chansons
qu'il avait l'air de dire aussi que tu
étais devenu quand même très court aux
rumeurs très quoi kooner c'est à dire
que tu étais avec chantal arthur les
quatre chats dans la maison vous avez
même style de vie si j'avais la preuve
que sortir jusqu'à 9h du mat tous les
jours en face de belles chansons je
crois on continuera à le faire
ouais à une époque où j'allais traîner
tous les matins de jaser parce que
c'était complètement tordue il y avait
des vieux films
il y avait sept dégueulis dans les
chiottes il se passait quelque chose de
touchant tu vois là rien c'est clean
comment tu vas
combien tu gagnes bon alors c'est un peu
le bilan de nos vies cela sur la
critique c'est parfait comme ça
ressemblait plus à appeler blessure qu'a
à rio grande et la critique a été
dithyrambique les ventes ça s'est passé
comment on va on va dépasser sans doute
à bosser bien me donne ce complètement
dit ranger sous anaïs en tentant savoir
que la veille
finalement même si c'était voulu
au fond de toi et avec le recul est ce
que la redescente après gaby après verte
et ça a été douloureux
maintenant on peut le dire moi ce que je
voyais c'est qu'effectivement il ya ces
deux tubes qui à un moment donné ont
montré que je pouvais que cette musique
pouvait être rentable mais mon but
c'était arrivé à faire des albums qui ne
se vendent c'est pas seulement avoir une
espèce de tubes et ensuite tu fais un
truc sur scène qui est vraiment toi et
tu passes ton temps à expliquer je fais
j'ai fait un tube mais vous savez je
fais d'autres trucs
bon ça st je n'avais pas envie d'être à
côté de mes pompes et je crois que le
les gens s'intéressent aux albums et
près là on va faire l'interview première
fois je me souvenais premier boulot je
dire mais j'ai fait un peu la
boulangerie ouais je j'étais un peu la
boulangerie je livrais des trucs que
j'ai livré des pièces montées pour pour
les communions pour les mariages ça leur
me donner une pièce c'était avant la
compass
ouais ouais premier fleurs elle
s'appelait ma région
avant j'habitais dans une dans un petit
village qui était tendance catholique
elle habitait dans un autre village d'un
kilomètre de chez elle c'était plutôt
protestons il ya des problèmes dans la
za on se rencontrait à mi-chemin dans
l'alsace ouais c'était l'enfer n'est pas
le droit de jouer avec les petits les
villes en face comme tu dis dans la
chanson
ba s'était coincée ou s y arriver les
juifs les protestants les cathos c'était
du vrai de vrai puis il y avait des
vieilles il y avait des idées des vieux
bouts de règlements de compte qui datait
de la guerre et intel qui avait dénoncé
l' intérêt et une telle qu'ils avaient
couché les grèves dès la rentrée la
france la france est la première fille
avec qui tu as fais l'amour souvient
ouest une brune ouais c'est pas terrible
c'était la sortie d'un cinéma on s'est
retrouvé dans dans un hangar entre entre
une moissonneuse batteuse et basket
landes un hangar
machines agricoles tu vas et
j'étais très vite fait vers 17 c'était
déjà mieux premier gars ont commencé à
prendre les garçons avec qui les fait
l'amour
aubert je suis encore vierge de ce côté
là aurait loué ouais je sais pas je jure
je me suis retrouvé dans un pieu avec un
mec comme ça il vendait comme un fouet
et met une touche et à ben comme ça et
moi je voulais dormir dans la rue
j'étais étonné par ce maître parce que
je le faisais bande et je trouvais ça
fascinant tap a essayé maintenant fais
gaffe c'est dangereux leur sert à
l'époque ça me paraissait dangereux
aussi
la thérapie première put 19 ans s'était
retirée charron se chanter dans un délai
des puces rue pierre charron y avait un
club qui s'appelait de club pierre
charon j'avais été engagée je devais
avoir 10 novembre comme ça et je
chantais cinq ou six chansons tous les
soirs avec une guitare sèche
mon porte harmonica j'ai chanté des
chansons de dylan mary mcdowell de trucs
comme ça
yves destruction des destructions a
grandement à ce que ce très bien j'aime
beaucoup et tiré des filles barre et
puis j'étais devenu copain avec m
on passait des nuits ensemble des x
files matin à nous payer d'espagne
c'était super
le protéger car avant j'aurais pu mal
tourner mais je ne voyais pas comment
des pages et quand on parle de cuite je
suis un peu choqué par le mou parce que
j'ai vu des filles super un premier
succès c'était beaucoup plus tard on
tété quoi le premier succès de gavin
jusqu'à dit rien c'était carrément ouais
on peut pas appeler ça il y avait du
bricolage partout entre le moment où tu
as décidé de devenir artiste et le
moment où tafer gaby il s'est passé
combien de temps dix ans dix en dix ans
puis accrue a forcément mais je
rencontre toujours un conte qui me
disait écoute c'est bien ce que tu fais
c'est bizarre a expliqué genre de truc
pourquoi tu tu insistes ou
c'est pas normal ce serait beau normes
et il ya peut-être certainement le fait
que
j'ai essayé de bosser je sais faire
détruire j'essayais de
mais je sentais tellement que il ya
décrit la vie pouvait pas être vraiment
fait avec et une envie de gagner de
l'argent comme ça je peux faire et
mourir ouais bah comme ça est devenue la
compta chez péchiney je te comprends
bien joué j'ai vu tout de suite que ce
sera peut-être mans si j'avais été
comptable il ya un truc ça marche pas
c'est les musiques de films ça fait
plein de musique de filles en fait cinq
suspects et lacombe s'en sortir pas pas
une je sois tu vas faire un cd un jour
avec les musiques de films de passion
mais je demande à temps j'aimerais
j'aimerais bien sûr 1,24 quelque part je
peux me dis que c'est un jour noir
collector's haythem un jour premier
million de nouveaux fronts oui quand va
se devait avec gaby ouais ouais
keystone ap je les ai pas vus en fait
les ai pas vus beaucoup il ya tout de
suite eu des impôts j'étais en train de
divorcer
c'était un ramdam
incroyable c'est ça qui est fantastique
quand ça marche parce que tu vois très
grosse île et les choses fantastiques et
tu vois grossi aussi la connerie est là
et la jalousie et tout ces trucs en plus
énormes aussi non premier procès
bondues bourse ouest on peut appeler ça
un peu ça s'est arrangé quand même elle
demandait beaucoup elle a eu très peu
elle demandait trop alors elle fait
attention menton
celle où est ta dernière volonté tu
devais mourir ce serait quoi on se
prendra un bain présentable